hello everyone welcome welc to another
episode of Q&A about history of Science
and
Technology uh I'm still not back in my
natural habitat so uh things may not be
quite as technologically perfect as
sometimes um let's see I see a bunch of
questions
here
um memes
asks what are the key requirements in
place for past scientific
revolutions you know I think
it's my impression is that sort of what
launches a scientific revolution is some
kind of new methodology either new
experimental methodology or new
theoretical
methodology and on the experimental side
what often happens is that there is sort
of an ambient growth of Technology
having nothing to do with science just
you know better lens grinding for people
to make glass classes or better uh or
Electronics amplification of electronics
or something like this or or computers
for that matter being built for some
completely different purpose and then at
some moment it gets realized gosh we can
use this technology for a method of
doing science typically maybe some
experimental method or some modern
computer experimental method or
something like this and then there's
sort of this this uh this sudden moment
when lots of things get opened up and
there's kind of a a lot of a lot of
change in the science I mean I suppose
an interesting question for today is if
we look at the whole neural Nets AI
story you know is that going to be
something where I think I talked about
this in fact last time is that going to
be something where uh kind of that
suddenly opens up sort of a a new
opportunities in science that didn't
exist before because methodology has
been developed for reasons having
nothing to do with science itself um I
think that's an interesting question I
consider that the uh uh that's still up
in the air I'd been working on a little
bit of you know to what extent can you
expect to use this new methodology to do
things that have been of scientific
interest before or and this is often the
case when sort of you open up new kinds
of experiments or something or new
methodologies that the questions you end
up asking end up changing as well
because it could be the case that there
are these oh there are these mysteries
in science and nobody can solve them
suddenly some new method comes along and
it solves those Mysteries or it could be
that some new method comes along and you
realize there are a bunch of new
questions that you never thought to ask
before you can now ask and we see that
for example with the llms uh you know
questions about sort of the the
structure of language the structure of
knowledge and so on that we didn't
really have a wasn't something that it
seemed to make sense to ask before this
but but now it does
I think one of the things that always
helps a scientific revolution is when
the place where it's going into is
fairly desolate that is if there's a
field that is where lots of stuff is
happening and everybody's very excited
that it's you know it's all being solved
and then some new method arrives
typically people are like oh but we we
we're getting we're making progress
anyway we don't need this new thing and
so there's less enthusiasm for it than
there would otherwise be
and you know so I think that that it
helps when sort of everything else is
burnt out and then suddenly there's this
um new spark of life so to speak that uh
that can then take off and can expand
sort of into a vacuum rather than having
to push back existing kinds of ideas in
that area so that's what be my
impression about um about what's what's
involved
there there's a question from Pierre
about the uh I think effective
accelerationism movement what history
led to it or influenced it I I I don't
know all the details of this I mean I
think the uh the general sort of pattern
of of whether it's um uh there's sort of
these General patterns of how can we
make the world a better place and
there's sort of the question of can
science help solve the question of how
to make the world a better place and I
think
that's a um uh the history of such
efforts is not particularly good I would
tend to think that the reason that it's
not good is because of my my friend
computational
irreducibility the idea that the the the
concept that you can organize the world
society whatever else in a certain way
by putting by sort of saying we know how
it's going to work we just put this
piece in place and that piece in place
and then we get to this point the fact
is that like like other systems that
have computational in reducibility when
you set down the system of rules the
system is sort of has an irreducibly
complicated behavior that it will follow
that will always lead to unexpected
surprising things happening so in other
words you say I've got this great idea
it's this utopian scheme and it's going
to be you know and everybody's going to
do the right thing and etc etc etc but
it turns out that the world in the in
you know sort of the the the fact that
there's computational irreducibility to
for example things like what happens in
society means that your perfect scheme
will always have a bug and that bug will
will come to to have all sorts of bad
things happening now it's sort of
interesting the extent to which there
are in a sense schemes like I don't know
capitalism or democracy or something
like this which have been reason
reasonably robust over the course of
time not perfect but reasonably robust
and haven't for the most part spluttered
out into into sort of complete uh horror
and it's sort of an interesting question
of why um why some of these sort of
approaches that feel a little bit more
inclusive in a sense and a little bit
less brittle seem to work better than
approaches that are more constrained and
more like we know what's going to happen
I mean I I think that there's a sense in
which in which sort of the the the the
kind of the
um the
more I don't know quite I suppose it's a
little bit like you know when you have a
material and the material can be very
strong but it's brittle you force it a
bit and eventually it cracks and just
breaks whereas if it's ductile if it
flows you can kind of you know things
change a bit and the thing doesn't as
dramatically break it is it's more able
to withstand change and maybe that's a
Criterion for some of these approaches
to sort of the organization of society
and so on I mean I I think that um uh it
would
be a
um it's it's kind of a these these
questions about where sort of you know
there have been there have been
approaches from you know Plato had
approaches to you know this is how to
set up the perfect uh system of
government and so on and you know he had
things which today we would be like no
no no that's horrifying you you
shouldn't do it that way and you know
the the philosopher Kings and so on and
his version of the aristocracy so to
speak of the the uh the power of the
best so to speak which is not what
aristocracy came to mean later on um but
uh you know that that there are many
things there which we now would think
well you know that doesn't really work
that well and you know in more recent
times I don't know Thomas Moore's
original Utopia and uh all kinds of um
all kinds of approaches of you know this
is how we'll organize things and
everything will be perfect um that they
haven't tended to end very well I think
in the um uh this question about you
know another feature of history is the
and This Time It's Different
belief I I think that history you know
one of the features of history is that
certain aspects of it do have a habit of
repeating themselves there a question of
why I mean in other words some part of
the repetition of History presumably is
because we're the same species as we
were you know 100 thousand years ago and
there are certain features of us humans
and the way that we interact and make
societies and so on that have been
unchanged over that period of time and
in so far as those are the Dy
of the sort of patterns of History those
things will repeat I suppose there are
other uh I mean there's there's a
certain and perhaps that's that's the
dominant effect I mean there may be
other effects like even the fact that
people know history and so have a habit
of of going back into the same ruts as
as happened in history but I suspect
that it's much more the Dynamics of our
species and sort of the the necessary
features of how the societ gets built
that lead to that kind of repetition I
mean it's always interesting that
there's sort of quantitative places
where people make use of the repetition
of History particularly in you know
quantitative Finance where you go
collect a bunch of data on how things
moved any time in the last 100 years of
you know this got more expensive and
that got cheaper and this and that and
the other and somehow those things
manage to be sort of successfully useful
as detailed predictors of things today
uh it's um I think that you know those
those kind of um uh lessons of history
that that's a very microscopic version
of how sort of lessons of History tend
to tend to be repeated I suppose one of
the questions that always comes up is
can there be a theory of history in
other words could there be some kind of
approach that says you know given that
this and this and this is happening it
is inevitable that such and such a thing
will happen I mean people say that about
sort of the you know as Empires get
older they build up more bureaucracy and
that leads to certain kinds of things
and and so on I I don't know to what
extent those are those are real effects
and to what extent those are various
kinds of sort of measurement uh biases
and so on I think it's certainly the
case you know one one thing you can see
in terms of the pattern of history is uh
it's kind of interesting to see you know
we have in in W language we have all
sorts of data on historical country
borders but pretty much all the ones
known in history you can kind of make
this animation of what did for example
Europe look like as a function of time
and you do see this kind of very sort of
physical biological looking processes
going on you know one country will puff
out over some period of 50 years or
something and take over lots of
neighboring ones and then there'll be
some moment where it pops and and goes
to practically zero as there's big war
and everybody overtakes that country and
then things keep going and so on and it
it gives one at least the sense I don't
know if it's uh you know the qualitative
sense that the Dynamics of what's
happening in that history are in some
sense kind of like what you would expect
in physical systems like what you would
expect in something where you could
imagine some kind of
predictability but uh uh the I suppose
um uh all these questions about sort of
what's the perfect way to set up Society
I mean you know even if you agree on
what the object Ives are uh and and
that's always a difficult thing to do in
fact not really a possible thing to do
in the end I think that sort of
computational irreducibility bites you
in terms of the ability to sort of uh
poke this or that but but I was also
going to talk about the and this time
it's different question and uh the issue
of whether sort of the technology we
have today is whether whether sort of
the the future of society is kind of um
uh going to be sort of whether the
changes that are happening today are
somehow very qualitatively different
from ones that happened in the past my
tendency would be to think not my
tendency would be to think until the
human condition has changed which might
happen if you know effective human
immortality is achieved or sort of
digital uploading of humans is achieved
those kinds of things that will
dramatically change the sort of common
experience of The Human Condition and
that could make things really profoundly
different I tend to think that the the
motion of you know well this job becomes
more important that one becomes less
important there's sort of less quotes
work of this kind to do I mean if you
look at the course of history sort of
manual labor work became less a thing
that people had to do uh other kinds of
work became more important the things
that count as work uh you know maybe it
counts as work to be professionally
playing video games or something which
is not something that would have counted
as work at some point in the past so I
think you know as as time goes on what
counts as work what people think is
worth doing um what is sort of scarce in
some sense changes and I don't think
that creates a qualitative change in
kind of the what one can expect for
society so a few comments there
um let's
see
uh boy you guys expect me to know an
awful lot of stuff here
um let's
see RBS is asking about binary code it's
historical rolling programming
connection to physical laws and so on
well let's talk about binary so the idea
that numbers can be you know we're used
to writing out our numbers in base 10
with decimal digits but it's been known
in one way or another certainly it's
been known with some clarity since the
1600s that you can as well write out
numbers in terms of powers of two um
instead of powers of 10 and then the
digits are just zero and
one I think that um the iching and the
hexagrams and so on of of ancient
Chinese uh kind of tradition were
certainly an example of where kind of a
binary like thing was constructed
remember when you when you setting up
kind of the binary numbers if you set
them up in a a fixed number of digits
you have kind of this tree structure
where you're saying well it's you know
it's a it's a a one branch or a zero
branch and you keep doing that a few
times and you've kind of constructed the
set of possible numbers correspond to
the possible Paths of the tree and
that's a little bit what happens in the
the hexagrams I guess of the eaching if
I remember my uh those kinds of things
correctly are are the various different
sort of binary configurations that you
get from doing that and that's been
something that's been sort of out and
about since Antiquity I think the the
time when sort of binary numbers kind of
became notable like gotfried lits in the
um uh in the late 1600s became an
Enthusiast of binary numbers whether he
knew about them from missionaries who'd
gone to China I don't think is very
clear he might have done um he uh
famously he made made a um uh he was
very proud of the binary numbers idea
and he had a medal that he wanted some
duke or something to strike for him uh
that you can find I found in his in his
archives kind of the the plan of the
metal and it says something like
um
uh gosh let's see if I can do it in
Latin
X um X Unum or something du kendit
something like that which means uh from
one everything can be descended so to
speak everything can be produced and
then he has just a a table on this on
this kind of metal thing of the numbers
in binary written up up to I don't know
up to I don't know 15 or something um
written out in binary digits and he was
very proud of this actually I I amum a
number of years ago uh I I've been a
livits Enthusiast for a long time I know
a number of other livits enthus
enthusiasts one is my friend Greg chaon
and for uh I think for his 60th birthday
I decided I would I would try and get
him a reproduction of this medal so we
we we we actually finally struck the
liet's medal so to speak um as hadn't
been done in Live's time and put a a
thing about Greg's work on the on the uh
reverse side of it but so I I had the
opportunity to take the um the the our
sort of struck version of the liance
matter
and uh when I was visiting the liit
archive a number of years ago and stick
it on the P page right by where liit had
had drawn the original version of the
medal But but so anyway livets was aware
of the idea of binary numbers they kind
of flapped around with nobody paying
much attention to them the only place
where they were notable was in kind of
uh sort of recreational math um I think
particularly in the in the late 1800s
that were a bunch of kind of math puzzle
books and they quite often talked about
sort of things you can do with digits
and and binary for example I mean I know
even when we were first building
Mathematica in the late 80s mid to late
80s that um you know there were
mathematicians who were sort of buzzing
around what we were doing and they were
like what do you mean you can have a
function that extracts the digits of a
number nobody cares about the digits of
a number they said numbers are just
numbers the fact that they're broken
into to digits is sort of
irrelevant now that that idea had well
as a matter of fact that very idea was
sort of thrown into into
incorrectness by things in dynamical
systems theory so starting around well
1900 or so this idea emerged of sort of
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions it was an idea that had had
existed in the 1800s people like James
Clerk Maxwell were aware of this idea
for example if you take uh two spheres
and you bounce them off each other if
they hit exactly on axis they'll bounce
back on axis if they h a little bit off
AIS they'll bounce back more off axis
than they hit so to speak and if you
keep bouncing back and forth they'll
you'll amplify the the small peration of
how far off axis they hit and that
amplification is an exponential
amplification it sort of let's say
doubles every time or something well
that same phenomenon on pineer around
1900 observed that same phenomenon in
Celestial mechanics that you can have a
situation where if you change the
positions of idealized planets just a
bit over time the positions that the
planets will end up will become
exponentially Divergent and then the
idea of leap of exponents leonov in
Soviet Union uh kind of in in studying
Control Systems sort of had this idea of
you can sort of measure the rate of
exponential Di diverence given that you
make a small peration what what is the
effect of that and when things are
stable there'll be you know a negatively
app of exponent the thing will will damp
out any peration you make when it's
positive it will expand it and that this
idea so so why is this related to digits
well the point is that if you have two
possible initial conditions and they're
very close together it's as if you have
the the if you write out the digits of
the number
it's as if the what what's happening is
when when there's exponential Divergence
it's as if you're you're Excavating more
and more digits lower and lower order
digits so to speak U smaller and smaller
digits in in the in the number so to
speak uh as as time goes on and so in
the 1930s in the origin of this thing
called symbolic Dynamics uh particularly
Master Mor was one of the the big people
in in that idea
uh later Garrett buroff um these are
American mathematicians um the idea one
of the things that was study quite a lot
was the shift map which is something
where you're saying just write out a
number in base two for example and at
every step let's say the number is X
compute 2x mod one so in other words
find the fractional part of twice the
number and so what that's doing is it's
gradually shifting the number one one
binary place to the left at every step
and so it's gradually Excavating more
and more digits so that's a place in
sort of the mainstream mathematics where
digit sequences became a thing and the
shift map the the binary shift the shift
map on on a binary sequence was well
studied that's in mathematics quite
different direction when people were
starting to think about making computers
when Charles babage was doing it in the
1830s 1840s his computers were all
decimal computers so his computers uh
involved little wheels that represented
a decimal digit and he didn't have the
idea of using anything other than that I
think it's it's sometimes claimed that
Conrad zuza um who was a German well
eventually sort of computer entrepreneur
who did some early work on computers uh
during the second world war it's a
little bit unclear exactly what he did
I've tried to track it down there sort
of a the mystery of a computer that he
built in his parents house and the house
was bombed but the computer had probably
been moved to an air raid shelter or
maybe it's in the collapsed basement of
the house and could be sort of
archaeologically excavated it's not
clear there's a single photograph of
this computer it's a mechanical computer
but it's claimed to have been a binary
based mechanical computer there's a
reproduction that um uh conad zuza made
with with his son before before he died
um and that claims to be the computer
although it doesn't look a lot like the
picture the one remaining picture that
exists of that computer but that's a
that's a claimed place which I don't
think connected very well to anywhere
else it was it was a project done uh
done partly during World War II um and
uh I don't think that was sort of what
connected to other things I think by the
time computers were being made uh things
like well atanassov's computer Iowa
State and then uh the ENC um uh done in
in uh in Philadelphia I guess near
Philadelphia um the uh uh those were
that by the time there were there were
actual sort of um digital electronic
computers being made those were
definitely using binary um as a way to
represent numbers I'm not sure that any
moment anybody said you know
dramatically o binary is the thing thing
we're going to do that there was still
ideas about using things other than
binary for example there was some
Russian computers um made I think in
what's now Ukraine I think in KV um that
were turnery computers and that was even
done in the
1950s uh where there were computers
where you could uh you know you would
have plus one uh where you'd have 012 or
I think they were minus
one01 and I think that was supposed to
have the advantage that when in in a in
a standard binary computer there's
always the question how do you represent
negative numbers the most common thing
to do for integers is two's complement
arithmetic that's sort of become the
dominant approach to it where the
highest order bit in the number is
flipped to represent negative and the
rest of the number is is uh is the zeros
and ones are reversed but there is some
awkwardness in that and I think this
Turner computer avoided some of that
awkwardness in dealing with negative
numbers it didn't catch on uh you know
sort of it went to to Binary computers I
have to say that when I was a kid in the
1960s uh there were you know kind of you
know I remember one sort of uh sort of
here's some cool things about math book
this must have been 1967 or something
like that and that book kind of had as a
as a wow look at this it's different the
idea of numbers in different bases and
you know pictures of octopuses and and
so on and uh for base eight and things
like this so at that time it certainly
wasn't the case that in sort of the
everyday uh you know that everybody knew
about number bases it was it was still
at that time kind of a slightly obscure
piece of knowledge um something that was
sort of part of the engineering of
computers but not part of sort of
everyday the everyday world I'm not sure
at what point in educational process
these days people learn about numbers in
different bases but uh uh there
certainly I think people tend to be more
familiar with the idea that their
numbers can be represented by sequences
of bits and so
on let's see I mean the the the whole
question of of sort of the relationship
between bits and um sort of physics well
that has its own story I mean this
question of whether physics is discret
or continuous has existed since
antiquity
and sort of got answered for matter at
the end of the of the 19th century and
for light at the beginning of the 20th
century those are discreet people kind
of thought space might be discreet back
in those days I keep on learning about
more examples of ways in which people
sort of thought space might be discreet
uh it was very hard to make it
consistent with relativity Theory and
people kind of gave up and said well I
guess space isn't discrete and that sort
of had happened by the 1930s or so um I
suppose my own efforts uh started again
in the 1990s realized that sort of the
idea of space as a as a grid wasn't
going to cut it but space as a network
most definitely was going to cut it and
that that was a way to think about
things now you know there had been
intermediate ideas John Wheeler was fond
of this it from bit uh kind of aphorism
that was a kind of create all of reality
from something which is fundamentally
well what I would say is computational I
don't think John Wheeler would have said
computational I'm not quite sure what he
sort of when he said a bit I think it
was more sort of a binary distinction I
mean that's a that's a thing that
reappears many times in both science and
actually sort of more mystical Pursuits
and so on this idea that sort of the
binary choice is what leads to
everything that was kind of the idea of
the iching that was the idea of uh there
were there were sort of subsequent
efforts Raman L had some although they
were not quite so binary but this this
notion that a a sort of sort of a a
single Choice distinction somehow makes
everything I I know George Spencer Brown
with his laws of form from the
1950s 60s I guess it's a form of
essentially Boolean algebra is again
kind of the um uh
uh the sort of this this this
distinction of of um one or zero you
know a distinction makes everything I
it's worth mentioning in the in the
midst of that George bu in the 1830s
with Boolean algebra and this kind of
mathematization of logic and logic after
all had also had this kind of binary
distinction of true or false now that
binary distinction of true or false has
led to all kinds of all kinds of
craziness and and complexity in logic
because you know the the characteristic
question is is it true that not not P
for any p is is is true so in other
words if I say it's not not raining does
that mean it's
reigning well it's complicated the that
is the LW of excluded middle that is a a
kind of a thing that people argue about
because you know if the if the thing
you're talking about doesn't exist what
does it mean to say not not p is equal
to P that's this kind of constructivism
sort of question in mathematics can you
assume the law of excluded middle you
know back in the in the 1920s and so on
the validity of the law of excluded
middle became some kind of bizarre
political issue and for example the
Soviet Union as it was kind of I don't
know my dialectical materialism well
enough but but um there's kind of a an
incompatibility I think between uh some
of that and and this notion of the law
of excluded middle so there was sort of
a a we don't believe in that and that
became kind of a logic meets politics um
uh kind of kind of thing I mean one you
know people always Sort of hope that
there are some things about what we as
humans do that kind of transcend the
details of kind of human society and
politics and so on and things like
mathematics and logic are often held out
as examples of that and that's a case
where where that wasn't really the case
but
you know this General notion of there is
this binary distinction true versus
false one versus zero I mean George bull
was the person who kind of merged the
idea of true versus false and one versus
Zero by inventing Boolean algebra which
was kind of like you know multiplication
is like or and addition is like and
except that true plus true if that's 1+
one it doesn't equal two it equals one
and George bull had to kind of smoosh
algebra to the ordinary algebra of
ordinary numbers to kind of deal with
this Boolean algebra but that's a there
are all these places where kind of this
this notion that you can get everything
from this one sort of Distinction uh
arose I don't think with great kind of
precision I think that the statement
that yes you can you know liit saying
you can get all the numbers from one and
zero uh kind of George bull saying you
can get kind of in the end one said one
can get sort of all the Boolean
functions from well that's sort of
obvious uh the these this kind of this
this idea that sort of everything can be
got with that one distinction I suspect
that's what led to John Wheeler's sort
of it from bit notion but I don't know
that history very well I I met John
Wheeler only once uh when he was in his
mid90s it was kind of a a bit of a bit
of an unfortunate meeting in a way way
because he really was quite uh quite old
and um I suppose in a in a piece of
rather sad moment I mean I I we were
sort of talking about some of my science
and so on and um uh kind of looks and
says to me you know uh you know who you
should talk to about this stuff there's
a chap over at The Institute I was
visiting him in in Princeton New Jersey
over at The Institute in Princeton he
said there's a chap over there named he
said it kind of slowly you know John on
nyman and um and I was like yes I know
he died before I was born and I think
this is a thing that even even at my not
terribly Advanced age I think one of
these things about s remembering the you
know what happened when and how many
years passed and you know is this person
you know that that was a that was a a
severe offset of kind of uh of of of
dates so to speak and I can see that
would
happen let's
see
uh
um lots of different questions here um
Eli asks I talk about the history of
cybernetics second order cybernetics and
its current connections to The Observer
and the
ruad well so cybernetics was kind of
originated that word was originated by
Nobert weer in the
1940s and uh kind of the notion was it
was all about controlling things this
how do you control stuff cybernetics
comes from the uh well Latin word Gator
meaning a Helmsman it's kind of like how
do you steer the ship how do you keep
things under control so to speak there
had been this notion of a governor that
had come into existence particularly
with steam engines I think James Watt
had invented a form of Governor where
you know things are spinning around
quickly and you have weights that as
they spin quickly the weights uh sort of
get pulled out by centrifugal force and
that pulling out causes a valve to close
and that slows things down and so you
have this notion of having a control
system having a way of keeping things at
a particular level kind of like in
modern times a thermostat might you know
switch on air conditioning or heat
trying to keep you at a particular
temperature now what's always tricky
about those things is if the thermostat
just says oops it's 71 degrees I better
switch on air conditioning oops it's 69
degrees better switch on heat the thing
will start oscillating like crazy and so
a lot of kind of the technology of
control theory has to do with making
controllers that sort of are sensible
with respect to those kinds of things
but this notion of controllability and
how do you set things up so that they
sort of stay within a certain required
boundary how do you make an autopilot
that will keep the plane at a certain
altitude and so on that that whole set
of ideas had originated with steam
engines and
things I think James Clerk Maxwell
worked on these things also in the in
the late 1800s um there had been kind of
a bunch of engineering done on that the
kind of theoretical ideas behind that I
think really originated during World War
II I think particularly in connection
with anti-aircraft guns um one of the
issues there is the plan's flying and
you've got to you know you shoot
something which you're trying to hit the
plane but the projectile is moving at a
certain speed the plan's moving at a
certain speed you have to kind of aim in
front of it and uh uh there's sort of a
feedback loop that is needed to achieve
that and I suppose that's the that's the
big thing about these Control Systems is
the notion of a feedback loop the notion
that you you will observe what happens
and then you use that to control what
you should do next You observe that you
know you put the heat on the temperature
goes up okay it went up this amount then
then switch the heat off and so on so
the theory of these kinds of things was
became very much a theory of of complex
analysis uh using complex numbers and so
on and doing all sorts of things that
that Norad weer had learned as a
mathematician um but when he got kind of
pulled into the anti-aircraft gun thing
in World War II got to apply those those
methods and sort of started making a
theory of control and that theory of
control for sort of when the thing is
very close to being in control you can
use a linear Theory you can assume that
there's small deviations which can be
approximated as as linear changes and
that gives you a whole set of sort of a
doable math that became control theory
meanwhile there was also a much kind of
uh more sort of uh ambitious version of
cybernetics that was kind of the idea
that that somehow this notion of control
would be also the how animals and
machines sort of figure out what to do
in general the general kind of planning
what to do what how do they respond to
stimuli these kinds of things not the
narrow sort of linear control of we've
got a thermostat and we're trying to
maintain a certain temperature and so on
um but that led to in the um by the
1950s this whole cybernetics movement of
we're going to figure out how everything
gets controlled and works it sort of
segwayed into what I would say in more
modern times might be related to kind of
complexity Theory and things that I sort
of developed in the 19 1980s although in
a rather different way and there were a
a series of famous conferences or the
Macy conferences organized by well fun
by the folks who did the depart Macy's
department store um that was a time when
kind of that was probably 1952 34 that
kind of time frame uh where lots of
people getting together to talk about
this this problem of sort of how do all
these systems like animals get to do
what they do people like Warren
mccullock Walter pittz the inventors of
the neural net from the 1940s were there
people like Margaret me
Anthropologist um I think John Von nyman
was there at some of these there's a
whole collection of characters and
there's also people like um chap called
Ross Ashby who was um uh sort of these
there were people and and a guy called
conad wton I think was part of this
picture some of those people were people
who were more on the sort of Let's Make
a mathematical theory of biology kind of
side of things then there were people
who were more on the well I I suppose
Nets was more in the psychology ology
Psychiatry Direction at that time and
then there was some kind of uh theory of
autometer kind of touring machine fin
out autometer type people those were all
sort of mushed together in this kind of
cybernetics movement and um it didn't
really work out very well they didn't
really figure out a lot the the part of
it that was control theory branched off
and uh um
was became sort of a a very practical
thing that's used all over the place to
do you know there's a there's all kinds
of stuff in W language for doing control
theory um and it's it's just a method
that's used in in lots of engineering
disciplines and so on but I think that
was kind of the the main ambition of
cybernetics had kind of died off by oh
gosh I don't know sometime in the 1960s
probably um I know when I was a kid
there were people were still sort of
talking about cybernetics and and
obviously the term cyber space and cyber
everything uh came from that same route
I remember there was a there a program I
maybe it's leing on there's this Doctor
Who program in in British television
which uh uh might be classified as
science fiction might be classified more
as comedy I suppose but but I think it's
it's changed over the course of time but
I remember this must have been oh gosh
1965 1966 something like that they had a
whole uh some of the villains for a
season or something were these
characters called the Cybermen who were
kind of cybernetic robotic kind of
future uh instantiations I think of uh
of our species or something like that or
perhaps they were from from from outer
space or whatever not sure but in any
case that was a kind of a typical of the
time kind of cyber uh cybernetics you
know we will we will computerize
everything we will mechanize automize or
autometer eyes everything but I think by
the I would say by the 70s um even uh
certainly by the 80s by the time I was
working on kind of how complex Behavior
arises from simple uh kind of rules
cybernetics wasn't really a thing there
was a branch of it that survived in the
Soviet Union and uh there were sort of
Institutes of cybernetics there which I
would say were on the more mathematical
end of things and ended up probably
doing more more surviving work than some
of the other parts one of the pieces
that came out of that whole cybernetics
discussion was this idea of second order
cybernetics sort of original cybernetics
is kind of a uh I suppose is a system
that well second order cybernetics is
kind of a A system that is that has the
Observer of the system somehow inside
the system and that as opposed to sort
of first order cybernetics where you've
got this I suppose where you you've got
a a system doing its thing and you've
got a controller of the system trying to
keep the system under control that's
sort of first order and second order is
the controller The Observer of the
system is somehow inside the system and
there are all sorts of lovely pictures
of eyes looking at eyes and so on John
Wheeler had drawn some of those I don't
think he really was thinking so much
about second order cybernetics um I
don't think second order cybernetics got
very far I mean I think it was mostly a
a sort of a concept of that's the next
thing one has to think about uh
certainly in recent thinking that we
have about the ruad and the idea of sort
of the Observer being part of the ruad
I've tried to sort of dust off some
things that um uh sort of historical
documents about um second order
cybernetics I have to say there's a
particularly weird book it's a very big
book what the who's the author oh gosh
maybe Gregory Bateson might have been
one of the people involved I'm not sure
um the uh uh but it's a book about kind
of cybernetic cybernetic everything it's
a very weird book to me at least and it
has sort of pictures of second order
cybern but I don't think it really got
anywhere I don't think there was ever a
sort of a formalism and by the way this
whole idea about sort of control and
observers and all this kind of thing
this
uh this idea of feedback control and so
on it was sort of rediscovered in what's
now called reinforcement learning
which is sort of a big thing in in
modern machine learning and so on um
those things it's kind of funny because
it's often happens in in science that
there are ideas which end up with sort
of parallel parts of evolution and there
are completely different names for the
exact same Concepts in these two
different fields and and that's happened
in that
case let's
see
uh see
here well
um well rather different let's see hold
on a second
um rud M rudo asked was the Cyber
definition before the definition of
Robotics I don't think so I think
robotics came from this word for a
worker in in in the uh Czech language um
in the
1920s late
1920s uh this this movie I think russoms
Universal robots or something robot I
think is is the word in in uh in the
original language um and I think that
was a thing that so that that word
existed by the 1930s
robot uh the term robotics I think was
invented much more recently uh I think I
think a chap called debal invented that
in connection with kind of um uh uh
Factory
Automation and I think you know Isaac
azimov kind of popularized robotics I'm
not sure he ever even you know knew the
person who' invented that term and maybe
he independently developed it from the
original robot
word as far as cybernetics is concerned
I'm pretty sure that was 1940s WEA and I
think that was a quite separate origin
from the whole robot thing
the term automaton is much older the
automatan word comes from probably was
existed even in the 1600s certainly the
notion of an automaton made from kind of
clockwork this kind of toy that would do
these things in a music box that would
have you know figures that went around
or or you know some some I know there
was a I think it was in the maybe 1700s
a duck that was made the rounds I think
in France that had you know the duck
walked and quacked and things like this
and had a lot of duck-like behavior and
it was kind of described as an automaton
um and uh that that was I think the term
automaton was used gosh I think it was
used in um uh in some philosophical
works by the 1700s for sure to describe
kind of what would happen if sort of it
was mechanically determined how a system
would work so those that term is older
um than uh uh than these terms robots
and and cyber and so
on uh ah Lazaro is saying you are
forgetting George Spencer Brown for
second order cybernetics I yes you are
right I'm I'm remembering that George
Spencer Brown did talk about this George
Spencer Brown was the originator of
so-called laws of form I think I
mentioned those earlier it's it's kind
of a a notational
reformulation of of logic of Boolean
algebra um that uh
uh sort of packages a bunch of things
into the notation of of writing sort of
hook things and so on but it's very big
on this idea of of start with the
distinction start with with this kind of
true false type distinction or just a
distinction and and sort of build things
from it you know I I once talked to
George Spencer Brown on the phone and he
was a wild character he's a person who
um uh you know if you read his resume he
was kind of you know he was a pilot he
was a psychiatrist he was a electronic
designer he was a oh gosh so many
different things I'm not sure um and you
know one of the things he produced was
this very kind of very very clean set of
ideas about laws of form very sort of
thin book um and uh that that led to
quite a a a movement I'm not sure that
it's engaged as much as it could have
done with sort of the formal machinery
of uh of working out working things out
mathematically I mean i' I've tried to
do that a little bit with with what he
did I I've not found it particularly
useful because it really is equivalent
to Boolean algebra and Boolean algebra
is a is a fine convenient thing to work
with I I am remembering that George
Spencer Brown worked on second order
cybernetics but I am not immediately
remembering what he did there um which
so I'm sorry about that um the uh
um uh oh yes you're asking did have I
used the ideas expanded in laws of form
uh not really I mean I I I think um the
uh yeah it's it's sort of a formal
system like other formal systems like
you could Define bullan algebra you know
I one of my little achievements back in
2000 was to find the very simplest axium
system single axium actually that leads
to Boolean algebra and George Spencer
Brown in effect has an axiom that leads
to the equivalent of algebra it's much
more complicated than the one I found um
but uh uh that's that's the um uh that's
the that's the thing
there let's
see
um there a question from robot Watcher
what was the significance of the ANC
computer so the ANC was what was it
electronic numerical something rather
integrator and something I think was
what it stood for it was
produced I think at the MU School in um
in in Philadelphia and was somehow in
connection with the aedine Proving
Ground which is a ballistics research
operation uh very active in World War II
but the aniac was produced I think in
1946 right after the end of the war and
um uh it was uh um Jay presper eot and
um William Morley I forget eot and
Morley were the the two sort of
principal people uh who were kind of
Engineers and then they kind of pulled
in as a sort of consultant John Von
noyman who was sort of a mathy person
and he was a person who um uh kind of
could matify anything and so he um he
ended up writing up nice fairly fairly
good sort of summary of sort of how to
think about sort of this electronic
computer idea in sort of mathy terms I
mean it's kind of charming he writes
about he he really describes things a
very biolog iCal way he's always talking
about organs by which he means uh uh
kind of gates what we would Now call
Gates electronic Gates he's talking
about as organs and he has a a very
biological nomenclature for things but
sort of this idea that you can kind of
connect Boolean algebra to to
electronics that idea had existed like
Claude Shannon's uh maybe Master thesis
at MIT had been about that topic of of
connecting switching Theory electronic
switches to BU albra that was slightly
earlier than that um but uh so you know
what emerged from and those those times
was sort of these design for sort of the
blueprint for a stored program
electronic computer you know Von noyman
certainly made many kind of mistakes in
a sense conceptual mistakes I think I
think that um it's always interesting to
study you know how smart people make
mistakes because it's a it's a lesson to
to all of us I suppose in in you know
what what you might think at one time
that might not be true in the future so
vman one of the things he said is the US
will only need five
computers and you know he could only
foresee the sort of the kinds of things
you might do with a computer to the tune
of there might need to be five of them
in the US obviously he didn't think of a
lot of the things that eventually got
used for what got computers got used for
the other thing he famously said was
there'll never never be a program
written that's more than I forget the
length you know 200 lines or something
long which of course isn't true either
that one I find interesting I'm pretty
sure that what vman had in mind there is
that he couldn't think of mathematical
proofs that ran to anything much longer
than that but the mistake he made was he
didn't think of sub routines he didn't
think of of subf functions so to speak
he didn't think now he should have
thought of that because if you've been
thinking clearly about proofs proofs the
proof of one theorem depends on other
theorems or it uses lemas those are kind
of like the sub routines of proofs and
so the unrolled thing with all of its
lemur and so on could be incredibly huge
you know it could be sort of the giant
textbook of all of mathematics or
something so he should have been able to
think of that um and that one I that one
I fault in for a little bit more than
the there won't need to be more than
five computers in in America but I think
from the ANC the basic design of the
aniac well John Von nyman made this
computer The Institute in Princeton the
I think the johniac I think it was
called I think there was a computer
there started to be these small numbers
of computers that got made in different
places IBM really got into that business
along with um uh um univac and sper oh
gosh I'm trying to remember honey
Honeywell was also in that business of
um uh uh these were I think univac was
the direct descendant of the ENC project
Pro that was the company um and and
meanwhile IBM also got into into the
business and people started making
computers but they were pretty art
artisanal uh things back in the early
days and the in the
1950s it was like there were a limited
number of these things and there's you
know one at Los Alamos there's one in
this place there's one in that place and
it wasn't really a a popular thing and
and and what came much later I mean
after IBM started sort of more mass
producing computers then you know there
were these moment when it was like the
first computer in India the first
computer in this place that place you
know those were it was a big deal when
that you know the first computer arrived
in in some particular country and so on
and I think the um the thing that uh uh
so you know my impression is that the
the sort of design the eniac was made
with vacuum tubes it was only few
Generations later when the first
transistor-based computers were made um
there were uh the I think the memory of
the of the
aniac was I believe was Mercury delay
lines um there were also British
computers by the way that were being
made at the time I mean it was it was an
interesting thing because there were
some countries that were making
computers the US the UK uh these were
making computers I don't know what point
the Soviet Union got into making
computers um but uh uh sort of the you
know it's one of those features of of
business history I suppose that the US
really made it into a significant sort
of computer Powerhouse and for example
the UK did not um and order did Germany
which is another place that had some
computer production um and uh the um I
think the thing that so one of the
things that was sort of an issue for
these computers is how would what was
their memory what was their storage
mechanism you know in modern times we
use semiconductors and we have uh uh you
know semiconductor memory and so on
but um in those days that that didn't
exist uh one of the methods was the the
um the Mercury delay line where you
would fill a tube with Mercury and you
would send a sound wave through that
tube to represent a one for example
you'd send a pulse through and it took a
while for the pulse to travel down the
the delay line you know this Mercury uh
this sort of thing of mercury and then
you'd pick it up at the other end you'd
amplify it and you'd send the pulse back
through through and so you kept your
memory uh it might be a little bit like
the way that that neurons keep you know
that we keep our short-term memories I
don't know in brains you keep it by sort
of circulating it through this thing
with a certain delay and that was kind
of the the early approach to memory in
in a bunch of in B of early computers
what got invented later by Jay Forester
was core memory um and that was the idea
of of uh having a magnetizing little um
uh donut-shaped little Tauruses magnetic
material and having these wires that
would go through those Tauruses and be
able to uh either magnetize or
demagnetize the Taurus and be able to
also read whether the Taurus was
magnetized by what happened to that
electrical pulse and for example the
first computer I used in 1972 had core
memory um and that was a that was sort
of a thing until until semiconductor
memory became the the standard uh
approach but so I think you know if you
were to trace I haven't ever seen this
but I'm sure one could do it sort of the
genealogical tree of early computers um
I I think you'd find that the aniac was
the the source of a whole bunch of
branches of that tree going into well
IBM and Honeywell and etc etc etc I mean
there subsequently was the usual kind of
um you know Clash of Titans business
interactions there were also many sort
of smaller computer companies because as
I say at the beginning it was an
artisanal business so to speak um and uh
the um you know it only became a mass
production business somewhat later and I
think that during the time when it was
kind of artisanal that was it was
readily possible for small companies to
uh to make computers um it only only
once there were serious production lines
was it became did it become more of a
big company kind of thing I mean I
remember when um when the first
workstation computers existed that was
1981 or so um you know the first ones on
Microsystems for example I remember
visiting them right at the beginning
they were wire wrapping you know that
they had these boards they had
microprocessors but they had to actually
sort of build the computer almost
autismal at that
time let's see a question here from
goola saying Isaac Newton was known as
the father of modern physics how might
he view advancements since his time
would he have anything to add I think he
was a bright fellow so I would think you
know there's always the question of how
long would it take old Isaac to learn
physics as it as physics has emerged I
think the thing he would have the
hardest time with is the abstraction in
mathematics the fact is in Newton's time
Newton was a very much a cleaner up of
of kind of mathematical uh presentation
I mean he really was the person who kind
of nailed down the idea of variables in
mathematics you know X and Y and things
like this and he also so well he
invented a bunch of notation like
fluxion the x dot kind of notation to
mean a Time derivative some of his
notation there didn't really catch on um
lienet his his sort of in some ways arch
nemesis the notation which in some ways
was worse of the dbx type notation did
catch on but um he uh
um the thing so so
Newton was in a
sense the thing that Newton was was very
successful at was figuring out just what
could you
mathematici you know there were many
questions in science there were
questions about sort of the orbits of
planets there were questions about you
know turning lead into gold there were
questions about uh all kinds of things
and what Newton managed to do in his
laws of mechanics particularly was he
got this little slice that was
mathematici it's not obvious that that
would be there like if he had chosen to
study fluid mechanics he would would
have had a really hard time coming up
with sort of simple mathematics to
represent what was going on I mean that
that whole idea of using simple
mathematics to represent sort of
physical things Galileo had been an
early user of that in discovering things
like the uh the quadratic relationship
between distance gone and time for an
object falling under Gravity things like
this um but newon really took that to
the next level and uh by sort of carving
out this one area of mechanics where
where there was sort of a thing not
acted on by any other Force the idea
that you could even identify a thing not
acted on by any other Force wasn't
obvious um that was something that he
had to make that idealization and then
go with it so to speak I think in
um gosh what would what would Newton
make of more modern developments I mean
I think if I were going to try and
explain you know if you imagine the sort
of time travel thing of um you meet
Isaac and uh it's probably um I wonder
what he would have been like he was he
was apparently people viewed him as
quite da I mean he was he was a bachelor
all his life and um although in his in
latest years when he moved to London his
niece Katherine Barton uh kind of kept
house for him and so on but I think the
um uh uh and I think that that was in
fact her her husband I think was um was
quite well connected in the government
and I think that was how Newton ended up
getting his gig as controller of the
mint um and but in any case the the um
uh the thing that
um uh I think he was a rather um uh you
know he said to been kind of a DA fellow
and um but yet it's also said that he
went to the local kind of pubs and was
very jolly there and I think you know
and mixing with the towns folk type
thing um so I mean maybe was one of
these people for whom I mean he was he
was an early professional academic he
was the Lucasian professor of
mathematics he was like the third one in
Cambridge it was a fairly recently
established Endowment for to pay for a
person who would spend their life
studying mathematics so to speak I mean
the concept of a professional academic
was was not that well established um and
I don't know what the um the interaction
with his his sort of fellow academics at
Trinity College Cambridge um what they
were like I mean many of those people
will have been theologians um Newton
developed his own kind of theological
ideas that I don't know much about um
but which were somewhat heretical in
their time um and I I don't know what
his his interactions about those things
were and maybe maybe he just didn't like
the academics and he was just fine with
the with the local towns folks so to
speak I I'm not I'm not really sure but
I think in terms of what um it's
interesting question what ideas you know
if you were explaining modern modern
Notions of
physics uh I think for
example the idea of atomism the idea
that atoms exist and that there are
discrete things in the world I don't
think would have been any surprise to to
to Newton I think that um he had kind of
got sort of Proto versions of kinetic
theory of gases although he made some
mistakes there kind of invent a
universal law analogous to his Universal
inverse Square law of gravity he had an
inverse fifth power law I think for
interactions between molecules that
turns out not to be correct and and
confus people for a while but I think
that um uh the the idea that there would
be discret things wouldn't have been
surprising to him I think the the kind
of the well so what would he have
thought of computers for example
um to it's an interesting question I
think if one had sort of you know it's
kind of a fun sort of thought experiment
imagine you show a laptop to people at
different times in history what would
they have thought it was I mean from the
you know Pythagoras who might have
thought it was you know disembodied
human souls in a box type thing to
Newton and I think his best model for
something complicated going on would
probably have been chemistry probably it
would have been you know this must be a
chemical process the idea that this was
ultimately driven by electricity would
be surprising to him and I think the
idea of sort of precision Electronics
prec Precision manufacturing and the
idea that you can pack a lot of stuff
into that little microprocessor that
would have been quite weird to him I
mean this was obviously before Newton
lived before the Industrial Revolution
it was at a time when there wasn't uh
there wasn't a lot of I would
say well the sort of the Machinery that
was built I suspect was in large measure
sort of you have a thing it's a chariot
you know it's it's a it's a carriage or
something it's got wheels it does this
rather than you have one machine that is
responsible for making another machine
that's responsible for making another
machine and so on I think that's a more
recent concept I think that's more of an
industrial revolution concept which is
which is sort of after Newton I think
the notion that you can kind of set up a
formal system which is sort of a a you
know something like wol language where
there's sort of a formal set of rules
for how the thing operates and then you
sort of see it run or something like a
cellular tomatan where you've got some
set of rules and then you see it run I
don't know how Newton would have
responded to that I think that uh that
sort of wasn't the kind of thing he was
thinking about I mean he was much more
thinking about I mean liet for example
was much more into those kinds of things
Newton was much more of a geometrical
kind of thinker and he he certainly
modeled his prinkipia Mathematica very
much after uet's presentation of uh you
know in nucleus presentation it was like
there are these axioms at the beginning
and from this we deduced geometry so
Newton very much wanted to structure his
deductions about mechanics from certain
axioms certain laws of mechanics would
then he would then deduce kind of
everything else about mechanics and he
presented things as you know scholium
and and theorems and things like this so
uh he was not I think even though the
the intellectual structure of that is
you start from rules and you produce
things it isn't the same kind of discret
formal uh writing it down with notation
kind of approach that liet was I think
closer
to oh my all sorts of questions here
well let's
see hiy asks a question what was the
history of small business versus big
business was there a shift in history
where one overtook the other well you
know governments are big business in a
sense and a lot of the early sort of
there were early joint stock companies
from the 1600s and so on in fact the
aforementioned Isaac Newton famously
invested in the in the south sea company
right which was a which was an attempt
to it was it was a stock you know a
company where you could invest in it as
a um and uh it was to sort of uh it had
kind of a license from the government to
kind of
um uh exploit the things in the South
Seas with all kinds of all kinds of
terrible stuff but um uh it was also
kind of a stock forward and um it uh I
think one of the more famous things that
happened was that the the king in
England and remember sort of was was
sort of in on the whole thing and I
think maybe was even the chairman of the
of the south sea company and at some
moment South Sea shares were going up so
well that they were like they were the
great thing to invest in and so the king
uh kind of people had had treasury bonds
and where they were lending money to the
government uh but there was a lot of
debt from the government and the King
kind of uh uh very kindly offered to let
people exchange their treasury bonds for
shares of the south sea company and uh
needless to say the south sea Bubble
Burst and really lost that money
including Isaac Newton lost some money
in that um and but the the the sovereign
debt of of the country had been sort of
uh sort of Spirited Away into um uh into
South Sea company shares I I have to say
it reminds me of some things that people
have proposed with cryptocurrency in
more recent times but um you know in the
in the story of History does repeat
itself uh one can see that but any case
I think that the you know these sort of
governmental companies um which by the
way you know there are certainly
countries in the world today where their
governments operate much more like large
companies than than uh sort of
controlling a lot of industrial
production and so on I mean that's the
that's the story in some places in times
there was kind of nationalized
Industries where you know the government
controlled the post office the telephone
system the whatever it is the railway
system whatever and those are and then
sometimes those got you know sold off
into into private companies but I think
this this notion that sort of there can
be a big company it was it was you know
back from the the 1600s for example that
was a thing that was very much entwined
with kind of licenses from the
government and the government letting
you do it and the government kind of
being involved D the the idea that you
could be sort of a thing independent of
the government I think Lloyds of London
insurance company is one of the older
kind of independent sort of you can make
a company it was I think a pretty big
company from the beginning because I
think it was you know in the insurance
business the goal is to spread the risk
over a lot of different assets and so on
um I think that um so that was a thing
but but in the I mean the other thing to
realize is the idea of a company in
which people could be investors
was was not you know that was probably
what the 1600s that was invented I think
um that that was a possibility wasn't
you know it was either the state the
government or it was just you know a
family owning a blacksmith shop or
something like this not a thing where
you could have you know a private Equity
Firm that had bought up all the
blacksmith shops in the in the in the
town or something like this by having
sort of invest owning things and so on
that really wasn't a thing I think
people were just doing business for
themselves so to speak there were also
things like the guilds which provided
some well both kind of a protection and
uh training and so on and sort of a a a
gaggle if if you're going to be a
licensed blacksmith you or these days it
we called licensed blacksmith but I mean
a um was it called gild little
blacksmith I'm not sure um that that you
had to be part of this thing but those
were not companies they didn't have I
think ownership they may have had some
dues that were paid but they weren't the
same kind of thing so I think I think
kind of this that what
enabled larger companies was this idea
of of they being investors and um that
that one could issue stock in these
companies and so on and there were lots
of terribly scarless things that
happened which in the US led to things
like the you know SEC being created in
the 1930s and so on I mean I think there
were there were sort of it was it was
kind of a a a huge scam uh huge kind of
potential for scams and so on in in that
kind of world before that but I think
this this thing that tends to happen in
industries of sort of you know they
usually sort of things aggregate into
bigger companies and then there are
little things that get left over I mean
it's a little bit like the map of the
world you know countries get bigger but
there's still countries that are left
over and maybe the big countries you
know don't survive forever and so on I
mean that's become less of a trend of of
uh sort of take over large parts of the
physical world it's more take over large
parts of the kind of commercial world
but I think um you know so I think
that's a uh um is there will there be a
trend back to smaller companies you know
I think I've seen in recent times you
know I've had a a company that's been
sort of an independent no investors type
type company for the last 36 years which
allows me to do all kinds of crazy
things that um that I think are
interesting um because I'm not sort of
uh beholden to a collection of of uh
purely financially motivated investors
it's um uh I think the you know the the
the trend among technology companies for
example has been get investors get
Venture Capital kind of build it up big
that way um and that has a certain set
of constraints associated with it I have
noticed in the last few years that more
and more people are asking me sort of
Silicon Valley folk and so on are asking
me wait a minute how do you build a
company that doesn't have those cut that
isn't an investor based company and that
maybe stays much smaller and doesn't
kind of puff out to be sort of the
biggest gorilla it can be so to speak I
think that um uh there's sort of a
question of what drives Big versus small
company is I would say one thing is sort
of the cost of getting started that is
if if the thing you're going to do
involves building a factory and the
factory is going to cost X number of
tens hundreds of millions of dollars
well you can't be that small if the
thing you're doing involves in modern
times doing you know $10 million of of
neural net training well you can't be
that small and still do that but at
different times in history and as
there's more automation and so on I
think it becomes much more realistic to
have small companies again in other
words at times when there isn't so much
automation where you have to have a lot
of investment in in stuff and people and
so on you can't have such small
companies when it's just a look I can
just you know with a oneman band so to
speak I can operate all these things and
set up all these pieces of software
insign in a sense our company there's
800 people or so but but is um uh you
know what I've tried to do is to
automate as much as possible so that
with a fairly modest number of people we
can do as much as possible and and
that's kind of a uh you know as you as
you scale that in different directions
once you make use of the fact that there
is automation for many kinds of things
you can scale down the size of companies
now there are forces that that scale up
the sizes of companies like just the the
way that the investment markets work and
so on and the fact that oh it's not
really worth raising Venture Capital
unless you you know unless it's a $5
million blob $10 million blob or
something the fact that uh you know by
the time you if if you're kind of
setting things up you can you know and
you've got the money to do it you can
hire lots and lots of people and that
sort of creates at least the appearance
of a kind of a barrier to anybody else
entering such a market so I think I
think probably automation drives down
the sizes of the needed sizes of
companies same is true with kind of the
the the Machinery of the world like like
if you needed to have have uh well
without credit cards for example if you
needed to take payments where everybody
is calling the people on the phone and
sending letters and getting letters of
credit in different countries and all
this kind of thing then you need more
people to do that and and you have a
sort of certain minimum size but by the
time it's all you know credit cards with
online processing and so on you don't
you don't need a you know there's no
there's no lower limit to the size of of
um uh that you need to be able to
operate those kinds of
things all right maybe one last question
and then uh should wrap up for
today
um lots of
um questions here they're a
bit complicated to
answer
um
well let's
see okay there's one question here from
uh Ki can you talk about the history of
traveling to space how come Moon visits
aren't more frequent because it's hard
at least right now it'll get easier I
mean I think that the original you know
the the first visit to the moon was
right a Russian sort of thing that was
just sort of thrown at the Moon that
arrived uh
like October of 1959 I think um that was
you know a couple years after Sputnik
um and uh was just like let's let's you
know throw this thing at the moon and
it'll just go Splat on the surface of
the Moon um and then there were soft
Landings a bit later than that um and uh
then kind of you know in the US for sort
of uh I would say political and national
pride reasons kind of when when John F
Kennedy sort of launched the let's go to
the Moon type thing um that was in a
sense it's kind of like a let's build a
pyramid kind of story it's one of those
things that actually is pretty good for
national pride and um and so on and in
that particular case you know probably
more I don't know probably building
pyramids led to all kinds of Technology
developments in that time but certainly
uh you know launching the Apollo program
led to all kinds of or became the Apollo
program became you know created all
kinds of technology that was useful and
then the big demo happened in in
whatever July 20th 1969 or whatever um
of you know land a person on the moon um
interest waned very quickly after that
by Apollo 13 uh you know by Apollo 11
everybody was like watching and cheering
and it was sort of a it was interesting
because it was kind of a a worldwide
Pride event in the end um which was you
know there aren't so many of those uh
but you know already by Apollo 13 I
think people had kind of lost interest
it's like okay we sent somebody to the
moon great we're done and only when
Apollo 13 had its problems then people
were like yeah it's it's exciting again
you know let's see what happens to the
spacecraft kind of thing but you know so
the the the enthusiasm for for going to
the Moon just wasn't very great and it's
like well why would you go to the Moon
well even now you know I've asked people
this who involved in modern space
efforts all the time why go to the Moon
well stepping stone to Mars why go to
Mars those are other questions you know
the thing that seems to be a popular
thing last couple of years is let's put
heavy manufacturing on the moon so we
don't pollute the Earth um and you know
that's a possible answer but I think
let's mine this or that on the moon
hasn't really isn't really seem very
convincing you know if you're a
scientist let's put radio telescopes on
The Far Side of the Moon so they aren't
messed up By Radio emissions from the
earth and things okay that's a thing but
uh you know it's it's not completely
clear what you know why go to the moon
so to speak and you know I I know um one
time somebody I knew was was promoting
the idea of you know bringing back
moonrock and treating it as a very
valuable thing like diamonds are treated
as valuable that would work well if
moonrock was kind of as cool looking as
diamonds are I don't think it is so
that's kind of
you know again that that plan isn't
isn't totally convincing I mean it's
kind of interesting that the that the
you know Moon Rock came from the Moon
probably you know people don't really
discuss that much possibly because the
the answers are a little bit messy
sometimes you know where did the
diamonds come from how did the diamonds
get produced in the in in the uh
pressure in the earth and so on and so
on but um I think uh so you know the the
the the principal question about you
know why haven't people been to the Moon
more well one it's hard and two it's why
do it I mean you know an indication of
the fact that it's hard is that even in
modern times a number of of efforts to
go to the moon have ended up with
spacecraft that didn't make it to land
Softly on the moon they just went splat
it was happened with this baret land
Israeli private isra project oh what was
it three four gosh maybe I'm losing TR
of time four years ago maybe
um a friend of mine had managed to put
some little sort of artifacts from our
civilization on that spacecraft
including some nice little micro
versions of of some things I've written
and so on um but uh which was sort of a
cool thing you know have your archive
your material on the moon unfortunately
some problem happened some you know uh
breaking rocket didn't fire correctly
and that spacecraft crashed into the
moon at high speed in fact subsequent to
that I mean just as a substory to this
the uh we were wondering you know what
happened to the thing it crashed into
the moon at what 2,000 kilometers an
hour I think um the uh uh it was it kind
of was almost still an orbit around the
moon I I forget the orbital speed around
the Moon is maybe 5,000 miles hour is
that right something like that anyway
and you know in order to land you have
to not be going around in orbit you have
to not you know it's not like on Earth
you can't orbit you know a mile above
the ground because there's an atmosphere
and and you'd be at 17,000 mph of of low
earth orbit velocity you'd be burning up
um but on the moon you can um the only
problem is if you're still going at that
speed and you hit the surface of the
Moon you're not soft landing on the moon
you're you're ramming yourself into the
surface of the Moon and I think the um
so there was sort of a question of what
happened to this thing and i' had done
this little calculation that if you if
if the thing had crashed into the moon
at the speed it had so so I guess one
knew two things when knew the last
picture that it had taken and we could
line that up with the craters that you
know pattern of craters on the moon and
then one knew at what time how did one
know that I think one knew at what time
it had impacted the moon I'm not sure
how one knew that um but or maybe there
was Telemetry actually yeah there was
radio signals from it which included the
velocity and things like this so I knew
it you know when it when it hit the moon
and it was going at a very high speed
relative to the surface not so much in
the downward direction as in the as in
the direction parallel to the surface so
the question is what happened to it and
I asked a bunch of people and uh the
initial people I I asked uh said things
like you know imagine you're firing the
main gun of a battleship at a piece of
concrete that's what will happen the
thing will vapor eyes but it turned out
that well then there was other data from
the lunar reconnaissance Orbiter taking
photographs of that site and you know
you could kind of see that there was a
difference of what the lunar surface
looked like at that spot before the the
the landing and after the landing so you
could tell there was something there but
anyway then I I actually uh ended up
making contact with a geologist I known
who's who died actually subsequently
person called Jay Melos who was an
expert in cratering and so he said well
actually if you are at that speed
relative to the surface um the thing
will not just Ram itself into the
surface it will Skip Along the surface
and actually I had worked out previously
that it would take a couple of
kilometers to come to rest just based on
friction and so on which really
surprised me it seemed very implausible
but apparently it's true that you can
kind of skid along the surface of the
Moon unless you run into a big boulder
or something and so then then it turns
out if you look at the pictures from the
lunar reconnaissance Orbiter there is
array of kind of light colored lunar
regolith that goes out in the direction
exactly the direction you would expect
from the vector of the velocity of the
of the spacecraft when it hit the moon
so probably the thing sort of bounced
along the surface of the Moon and quite
possibly the little payload is still
intact there um on the moon but anyway
it's that was just a the story of that
particular mission was just a you know a
reminder that it's actually hard to you
know to correctly land soft land
something on the moon and uh so I think
that's that's one of the main reasons
now my guess is that the sort of
engineering of Landing things on the
moon will be fully solved in the next
few years and it will become perfectly
feasible to do that then the big
question is okay if it if it can be done
and it's even fairly cheap to do it what
will be the consequences of that what
will you be able to do um on the moon
and you will in fact will will there be
you know will it be a giant story of
putting factories on the moon or will it
be something quite different I'm not
sure anyway a few thoughts about those
kinds of things well thanks for asking
lots of interesting questions and uh we
should wrap up for now and uh until the
next time bye for
now